bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce premier numéro du 78 loisirs vos
idées sorties dans le département on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
AB Bois d'Arcy peinture et sculpture ont
investi l'espace baragué une exposition
consacrée aux artistes de la ville à
l'occasion de la sing-ie vous la
découvrirez dans votre rendez-vous dédié
aux sortis junior il sera question de
cirque wifedri nous rejoindra en plateau
pour nous présenter les atelier du
chapitau mimelo à Versailles enfin nous
parlerons sport et surtout tumbling une
discipline encore inconnue qui défie les
lois de la
gravité pour commencer un rendez-vous à
noter dès maintenant le dimanche 25
septembre la larie de la reine à
Rambouillet nous emmène faire un bon
dans le passé le temps d'une après-midi
acteurs artistes et personnels du
domaine invitent les curieux à l'époque
de Marie Antoinette costume d'époque
exigé les inscriptions peuvent se faire
par mail ou par téléphone jusqu'au 19
septembre anneclair nerol chargé
d'action éducative nous en dit un peu
plus sur cet
événement pour essayer de vraiment
transporter le public dans cette époque
du 18e siècle des Lumières euh on a fait
intervenir un certain nombre de
personnes pour mettre en place des
activités par exemple des activités
musicales des activités de danse
d'époque euh une activité de dégustation
de macaron euh une activité de théâtrale
évidemment on va avoir les pièces de de
théâtre qui vont se jouer tout au long
de la journée je vous le disais en titre
dans le cadre de la saint-gill 58
artistes arcisiens présentent leurs
travaux à l'espace baraguet diverses
techniques de peinture sculpture et
photographie sont exposées jusqu'au 16
septembre Corine Fallin nous l'a fait
découvrir promouvoir l'art et la culture
pour tous en exposant les œuvres
d'association mais aussi de particuliers
tel est l'objectif du Salon des Artistes
arsisiens organisé à l'espace baragué le
le principe c'est vraiment de faire en
sorte qu'on a des artistes au sein de
notre ville les arcisiens et qu'on leur
donne la possibilité d'avoir un espace
pour pouvoir exposer c'est important
exposer pour les arcisiens et comme
chaque année il y a de plus en plus de
monde qui vient les regarder et ça nous
fait ça permet à tout le monde de
découvrir des nouveaux artistes des
nouvelles techniques diverses techniques
sont en effet exposées comme les
énigmatiques masques de Racou de
Marie-France Gilbert
les sculptures longilges et délicates de
Bernard
Hubert la charismatique statuette
d'esmeréralda de Christian pléo ou
encore les grands formats de Pascal
Salin et les impénétrables regards de
ces mystérieux
personnages on va retrouver aujourd'hui
des artistes qui sont de la peinture que
ce soit de la sculpture et dans la
peinture on va aller du du pastel gras à
tout ce qui est d'ordre classique
jusqu'à aujourd'hui retrouver des
artistes qui font du Posca et voir mixer
différents différentes formes en fait de
toile pour découvrir ces multiples
techniques de peinture photographie et
sculpture des artistes artisiens
rendez-vous à l'espace baraguet jusqu'au
septembre nous passons maintenant à
notre entretien terésina perira le
compère nous a rejoint pour parler
littérature avec son association arbre
elle a lancé au mois de mai une
bouquinerie à Montini le Bretonneux
bonjour thésina bonjour merci de m'avoir
invité mais de rien merci d'être venue
alors tout d'abord expliquez-nous
qu'est-ce qu'une bouquinerie alors une
bouquinerie
c'est une nouvelle vie pour les anciens
livres les livres que les gens ne
veulent plus et qui peuvent aller
justement alimenter le savoir d'autres
personnes donc on les vend pas cher du
tout entre 0 50 pour un que SGE jusqu'à
3 pour un classique alors la différence
avec une librairie c'est ça c'est que
chacun vient faire un peu un troc un
échange voilà c'est une sorte de
recyclage des livres en fait hein
d'accord on vend pas des livres nouveaux
sinon ça serait une concurrence vraiment
déloyale avec avec les librairies on
vend les pour alimenter l'association et
pouvoir continuer à acheter d'autres
livres mais vous proposer également des
ateliers écriture voà ça c'est notre
corps notre essence même
d'arbratex c'est d' proposer aux
personnes de de de de construire des des
textes des lire des livres différents de
faire des lectures des commentaires et
tout ça parce que nous avons un
potentiel énorme que nous
ignorons donc c'està-dire c'est quoi ce
ce potentiel en fait l'idée c'est de
rendre la la lecture et l'écriture
accessible à à tous et oui surtout que
les gens si l'appropri les prennent et
et écrivent et lisent et lisent beaucoup
parce que le savoir il nous permet de
voyager de nous échapper du quotidien de
même si on aime le quotidien j'espère
alors comment est-ce qu'on s'inscrit à
ces ateliers justement si on veut
s'inscrire comment est-ce que ça se
passe alors donc nous avons un
un un email hein qui texte
@ euh
wanado.fr vous pouvez vous inscrire hein
parce qu'on n'est pas riche donc on peut
pas avoir un site ou quelque chose comme
ça et voilà les ateliers ont lieu quand
les gens le peuvent il suffit qu'il y
ait un groupe de cinq personnes pour
qu'on ouvre un atelier par exemple des
lectures romantiques des poèmes et après
on passe à l'écriture mais il faut
vraiment avoir une pratique de la
lecture pour et donc vous travaillez
différents styles d'écriture c'est ça
oui voilà journalistique par extique
aussi et vous vous-même vous Azé cet
ateliers vous êtes écrivain alors moi
mon mon rêve oui je suis j'ai j'écris
beaucoup beaucoup de choses j'ai une
cinquantaine des poèmes des portraits et
là j'ai j'ai la chance il y a les
Presses Universitaires d'Europe qui va
publier mon roman qui s'appelle
métaphore métis c'est l'histoire d'une
amitié entre une femme française et une
femme brésilienne et voilà il y a une
rupture amoureuse et on va construire
plein d'images pour éloigner la
souffrance et et aussi construire autre
chose et alors un mot sur l'association
arbre àexte quand est-ce que ça a été
créé quelle valeur est-ce que vous
transmettez justement
1979 ça a été créé j'ai formé et une
vingtaine des jeunes s étudiants et des
voisins hein donc les voilà et on a fait
un journal qui s'appelle écrit libre qui
a été trouvé par les personnes
et je me rappelle plus l'autre question
et du coup euh oui c'était du coup
quelle valeur est-ce que vous vous
transmettez en fait par cette
association pardon oui pardon
excusez-moi je vous a coupé alors
euh qu'est-ce qu'on transmet c'est de
direire aux p sonne qu'on a tous un
potentiel énorme qu'on ignore parce que
le parcours parce que l'école parfois
n'a pas répondu à ce qu'on souhaitait et
cetera et donc il faut il faut que ces
potentiels sortent et qu'il sortent à
travers la lecture et l'écriture un
dernier petit mot sur ceux qui veulent
vous rendre visite rapidement quels sont
les horaires d'ouverture alors en ce
moment je fais deux permanences au CIN
rue Nicolas boilot oui l'adressesse peut
s'afficher en bas de l'écran d'ailleurs
je pense et c'est quel jour c'est le
mercredi et le le samedi de 14h à 17h30
ben très bien merci beaucoup th de nous
avoir présenter ce beau projet si vous
vous sentez l'âme littéraire l'adresse
de la bookinerie s'affiche en bas de
l'écran on passe tout de suite à la
citoyenneté à guillancour guillancour
amorce la rentrée avec une exposition
dédiée à cette notion la citoyenneté à
travers des archives issues des
collections municipales et
départementales l'exposition propose de
s'interroger sur ce qui fait de nous un
citoyen elle est à découvrir jusqu'au
1er octobre à l'Hôtel de Ville les
images de Mélanie poet elle donne accès
au droit de vote et à la liberté
d'expression c'est la citoyenneté depuis
le 8 septembre Guy en cour lui consacre
une exposition un moyen de raconter
l'histoire de la ville au travers de
documents issus des archives municipales
et départementales le thème des journées
du patrimoine justement sont sur la
citoyeneté et c'était vraiment
l'opportunité d'une rentrée rentrée
scolaire bien sûr rentrée culturelle
aussi mais c'est aussi rappeler les
symboles les devoirs les droits bien sûr
droit de santé droit de logement découpé
en plusieurs thématiques l'exposition
évoque la notion de citoyenneté les
devoirs du citoyen ou encore les
symboles de la République une des pièces
maîtresses à retrouver la liste
électorale de 1944 où figurent les
femmes pour la première fois
l'incription des femmes sur les listes
électorales et l'accès au droit de vote
pour les femmes a été édicté par une
ordonnance du général de Gaulle en 1944
et c'est à partir de cette époque que
les femmes acquèrent leur citoyenneté
complète finalement sur la cinquantaine
de documents présentés la majorité sont
des originaux certains n'ont jamais été
exposés ces témoins du passé de la
citoyenneté sont à découvrir à l'hôtel
de ville jusqu'au 1er
octobre
comme chaque vendredi dans le 78 loisir
nous vous proposons une séquence dédiée
exclusivement aux juniors comment
occuper vos enfants aujourd'hui c'est
Wilfried Richy qui vous propose de les
initier aux arts du cirque bonjour
Wilfried bonjour Camille nous allons
partir pour versaill dans le quartier de
Porsche fontaine où se trouve depuis 10
ans le chapitau mellimélo alors c'est à
la fois un lieu de résidence pour les
artistes une salle de spectacle mais
aussi une école de cirque avec des cours
qui sont proposés pas uniquement aux
plus jeunes d'ailleurs on peut
s'inscrire si l'on a entre 1 ans si on
commence marché jusqu'à 77 ans écoutez
le directeur du chapitau on a un atelier
qui s'appelle l'atelier parents enfant
et qui est donc là c'est pour les
enfants de 1 an à 3 ans accompagnés de
leurs parents c'est très drôle c'est
enfin c'est très drôle c'est souvent les
parents qui en bavent le plus après on a
des ateliers de 4 7 ans ce qui
correspond est plus en terme de scolaire
c'est des moyennes sections ACP après on
a des ateliers 7 9 ans donc là ça
correspond un peu au primaire au milieu
du primaire et et puis après on a des
ateliers 9 12 c'est le le passage du
primaire au collège et des ateliers ados
et ensuite des ateliers adultes il y a
pas de compétition c'est quelque chose
qui est sans compétition donc ça on fait
on fait de l'acrobatie sans compétition
pas comme la Gy où il faut être premier
et cetera donc c'est c'est ouais c'est
pour certains c'est bien
et tout cela est très sérieux le chapito
mimelo met en avant à la fois un projet
éducatif et pédagogique alors pour le
projet éducatif l'ambition c'est de
favoriser le travail en groupe fonderé
sur l'aide et l'entraide mais aussi de
participer au développement physique au
renforcement de la confiance en soi vous
pourrez ainsi pratiquer les différents
agrès circassiens découvrir et c'est en
tout cas ce que nous promet l'équipe
d'enseignant des sensations corporelles
inhabituelles rien que ça et pour le
projet pédag pédagogique pardon on
retiendra notamment que ces cours
permettent de faire l'expérien de la
persévérance mais aussi de prendre
conscience de l'autre respect entraide
quelquesunes des valeurs donc du cirque
qui sont forcément très prisé par les
parents qui inscrivent leurs enfants
c'est donc vous l'avez dit très sérieux
et on l'a vu aussi sur ces images ça
n'empêche pas les enfants de s'amuser
ils s'amusent d'autant plus qu'ils ont
une grande liberté notamment par exemple
lorsqu'il faut élaborer le programme du
spectacle de fin d'année on laisse le
choix aux enfants dans les créations
c'est donc un moment au mois d'avril ou
quelque chose comme ça pour le spectacle
du mois de juin mais on en fait aussi en
décembre on leur propose on leur dit
vous avez envie de faire quoi donc ça
peut donner des choses comme des fois on
a des spectacles avec le Père Noël ça
c'est souvent à Noël je sais pas
pourquoi mais il y a Louin ou des choses
comme ça des thèmes comme ça mais ça
peut être des thèmes aussi dans les
thèmes complètement fous j'ai eu une
fois sur la folie des enfants qui ont
décidé de travailler sur la folie
c'était très intéressant les ados sont
justement c'est là où on voit des
spectacles qui sont très peut-être pas
avec des grosses thématiques mais par
contre avec des gros euh c'est assez
noir souvent ce qui monte et c'est mais
ça reflète bien donc pour eux c'est une
manière de parler aussi autrement
qu'avec des mots mais de donner des
ressentis des choses comme ça alors
maintenant que vous avez convaincu les
enfants et leurs parents est-il encore
possible de s'inscrire pour cette saison
et bien non trop tard les places sont
rares il est uniquement possible de
demander à être inscrit sur les listes
d'attentes en revanche il est encore
possible de s'inscrire pour les ateliers
qui sont dispensés pendant les
différentes vacances scolaires il y a
deux ateliers pour les 4 7 ans et puis
l'autre atelier c'est pour les 8 12 ans
et cela coûte entre 50 et
20 € pour qu leçons sur la semaine merci
beaucoup Wilfried pour toutes ces
informations les contacts s'affichent au
bas de votre écran et on quitte
maintenant l'univers du cirque pour le
sport ou plutôt le tumbling dimanche
dernier il s'est invité au ha champ de
plaisir le club des classes sous boois a
organiser des démonstrations pour faire
découvrir ce sport proche de la
gymnastique acrobatique on découvre tout
de suite cette discipline sur les images
de Mélanie
poquet flip double salto ou sopéeux en
tumbling il faut savoir rebondir
objectif de la discipline effectuer une
série de H mouvements sur une piste de
25 m de long à plaisir le 4 septembre le
club des class sous bois a fait
découvrir ce sport aux spectateurs une
mise en lumière pour cette discipline
entre pirouette et gymnastique c'est
vraiment prendre de la rapidité percuter
le plus haut possible et puis prendre le
plus de plaisir en l'air à faire nos
acrobaties quoi c'est savoir contrôler
cette vitesse pouvoir profiter à fond de
sa vitesse savoir la bloquer aller le
plus haut possible c'est pas du tout
connu malheureusement c'est super
impressionnant à chaque fois que qu'on
fait des démonstrations ou ça marche
super bien seuls les contacts avec les
pieds et les mains sont autorisés en
compétition les séries sont notées par
des juges qui évaluent l'athlète selon
la difficulté et l'exécution des figure
avec des sauts pouvant aller jusqu'à 4 m
de hauteur le tumbling défie les lois de
la gravité pour faire du tumbling je
pense qu'il faut il faut avoir une bonne
dose on va dire de dynamisme même si la
piste elle rebondit tous nos athlètes en
général ce sont des enfants qui à la
base sont vraiment très énergiques un
minimum de souplesse et requis quand
même on fait toujours des exercices
d'assouplissement et puis il font aussi
des abdominaux de la musculation puisque
c'est un sport quand même qui est très
physique plusieurs cours sont organisé
au CLA sous boois allant de l'initiation
avec un cours par semaine à TR cours par
semaine pour les plus expérimenté
actuellement le club de la ville compte
une soixantaine
d'adhérents
de rendez-vous à noter pour samedi dans
vos agendas au gymnase des droits de
l'homme à guillancour vous avez
rendez-vous avec praline guepara elle
vous accueillera dans sa roulotte pour
vous faire voyager à l'aide de compte
traditionnel et récit du monde entier
ensuite le Crazy Town festival il y en
aura pour tous les goûts avec du rock du
régaet ou du blues une deuxème édition
qui se tiendra à tiival Grignon ce
samedi dès 15h au total 6 concerts dont
la tête d'affiche sabor qui reprendra
les titres de Santana avis aux amateurs
c'est la fin de ce 78 loisir merci de
nous avoir suivi je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là très bon weekend à
[Musique]
tous